Probably the single most important thing a leader has is trust of followers.
Right? There's not a leader if there are no followers.
And any follower takes a leap of faith...
...in pretty much suspending your own judgment and trusting the judgment of somebody else.
Trust is all you have.
It's hard to build, it's easy to lose.
And you know, in the era of new communications tools where you're constantly...
...being exposed for good and for bad.
I think the, probably the most important tool that a leader will have going forward is...
...how to use all the tools at your disposal...
...to build trust, to preserve trust and not to lose it.
The most important skill that leaders of the future need...
...is a clear sense of their calling, of their purpose.
You see so many leaders that are technically confident,...
...wonderfully skilled, either in technical knowledge...
...and skills or whatever their trade or the craft is,...
...we're just not sure in the service of what,...
...why, the bigger questions.
When we find this search in all of our students, we find it in executives...
...all the way down through elementary school. I mean the search for meaning,...
"Why am I doing what I'm doing?"
So that clarity of purpose for me is the base,...
...the bedrock of what leaders of the future need.